und wenn die politiker auf die idee
kommen mir dass ostern wieder
aufzutragen bin ich nicht ganz sicher ob
ich noch mal mitmachen
die ausgangs beschränkung mainz jetzt
oder selbst dran ii feiern weil das ist
ja schon einer der wenigen sachen die
beschlossen sie erfinde ist also
sozusagen einen offenbarungseid der
politik dass sie ihr eigenes versagen
beim impfen und testen an den menschen
aus lässt an ostern ja für viele
vielleicht sogar das noch wichtigere und
schönere und familiäre fest als
weihnachten mindestens auf gleiche auf
gleicher ebene den menschen zu verbieten
mit dem gestus ihr müsst jetzt sozusagen
ihr dürft jetzt nicht ostern feiern weil
wir zu doof waren genug impfstoff zu
bestellen
ihr könnt eure verwandten nicht treffen
weil wir es nicht geschafft haben den
test strategie zu etablieren wie viele
viele andere staaten das aber geschafft
haben das glaube ich wird ostern zu
einem gut festmachen